joe biden's beloved son is in hot water
again after messages show him using the
n-word the race-baiter's double standard
remains on full display
and kamala harris continues to be awful
at her job i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first let's be clear about
something when it comes to father's day
there's one gift that rises above all
the others and i'm talking about
underwear
hey tommy john underwear this is the
best stuff on the planet it graces
the tuches of yours truly at this very
instant all dads agree
when they're wearing tommy john
underwear they're much more comfortable
they can do everything better which is
why tommy john doesn't have customers
they have fanatics
hundreds of thousands of them who after
13 years and tens of thousands of five
star reviews
call tommy john the most comfortable
underwear ever i mean they really are
that good
i threw away all my other pairs of
underwear i only have tommy john now
that breathable lightweight
moisture-wicking fabric with four times
the stretch
of competing brands with over 14 million
pairs sold dads across
america love tommy john underwear and
there is no risk because your dad is
always covered with tommy john's best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee head on over to tommyjohn.com
ben for 20
off your very first order right now
order by june 15th
for delivery by father's day so you got
to get on this one right now get 20
off your first order at tommyjohn.com
that is slash tommyjohn.com see the site
for details they really are terrific
underwear by the way they also have
products for women as well go check them
out
tommyjohn.com and see their site for
details alrighty so
as it turns out hunter biden a man that
joe biden once called the smartest man
he knew
is not in fact the smartest person in
the world now
i know you find all that shocking
consider considering hunter biden's
history
of basically just running around the
globe picking up bags of cash by saying
his last name over and over
and his history of smoking parmesan
cheese off of carpets
he thought it was crack to be fair to
him and his history
of apparently stopping his brother's
widow while also trying to seduce his
brother's widow's
married sister yes that's a thing that
happened but now we have the most
explosive
allegation of all because we live in the
craziest world of all and that is
that hunter biden addressed his white
lawyer as n-word
multiple times use phrases like true dat
and word
and bantered i only love you because
you're black in shocking tasks
unearthed days after joe's emotional
tulsa speech decrying
racism according to daily mail in the uk
now again i will say that our general
moral standards in the united states are
somewhat weird
and they're somewhat weird that that if
you jesting
and ingest use the n-word that ends with
an
a to describe your white lawyer that
this
is in the world of politics a much much
greater sin
than being a crack addict who
is irresponsible with his own children
and also knocks up a stripper and
also is stopping his his
brother's widow and also her married
sister like
in the pantheon of sins i feel like we
were sort of getting these out of
order but suffice it to say hunter biden
is a garbage person
has been a garbage person not not as
like he actually picks up garbage like
he's actual person made of garbage he's
a terrible terrible person he's been a
terrible person for a very long time it
is constantly a source of amusement to
me
how the media continued to treat hunter
biden as though he is again
a small child even though hunter biden
is i believe 52 years old
if at 52 years old you are still
participating in these sorts of high
drinks
at this point i think we can safely
declare that you're not a very good
person
but it does expose to the to two lights
the fact that there is this wild double
standard with regard to the sort of
language that you're allowed to use
so long as you are apparently related to
a prominent democrat
now we've known this for a long time
right your behavior if you're a
prominent democrat
there are very few boundaries on what
you can do unless you happen to become
useless to the democratic party
right hunter biden is still useful
because his dad is useful
the minute that joe biden becomes not
useful hunter biden will be not useful
anymore and he will go the way of the
dodo bird he saw this with bill clinton
right bill clinton went from being so
useful
that people were making excuses for rape
allegations against him
then he became not super useful and
everybody's like ah that bill clinton
he's just terrible and then he became
useful again
around the time that hillary was running
and then we had to downplay everything
that was bad about bill clinton
and then he became useless again and now
he's kind of useful again so anytime
somebody is useful to the democratic
party they become useful to the media
and then all the stuff gets downplayed
anytime they are useless to the
democratic party then it's totally safe
to throw them out the window
okay so here is the full story about
hunter biden now
again i will say that when it comes to
the use of the n-word
there is a difference between calling a
black person
an n-word with an e-r at the end and
in ingest using the n-word that ends
with an a to describe a white person now
the latter is also really crude and
gross and stupid it's not racist in the
same way that it would be if you're just
shouting the n word
at a black person which is the height of
racism obviously in american society but
here is the story from the uk daily mail
hunter biden used the n-word multiple
times in conversation with his white 845
per hour lawyer his text messages
revealed the shocking text may prove
embarrassing for his father joe biden
who just last week gave a speech to
crying racism on the 100th anniversary
of the tulsa massacre and has sought to
portray racial justice as the top
priority
for his administration the president's
son joked in a january 2019 text to
corporate attorney george maseras about
a big penis
and said to the lawyer i only love you
because you're black and
true dad and word in another text a
month earlier he wrote to the chicago
lawyer saying
how much money do i owe you because with
two a's
because edward you better not be
charging me hennessy rates
me sirius wrote back that made me snarf
my coffee because he's a lawyer and
lawyers know that you're supposed to
actually just like pretend that your
clients are amusing
hunter added that's what i'm saying
n-word cutting off the racial slur
mid-word then texted a picture to
missouri's
and the picture was not downloaded on
hunter's laptop from which the text
exchange was recovered by daily mail but
missouri's replied why are you so tan
hunter replied i'm sorry for sexting you
accidentally that was meant for another
friend
named georgia in the january text
exchange the two men were talking about
philosophy and bantering with each other
mysterious wrote there are ideals of
unconditional love that serve as proxies
i don't have many you god hunter wrote
omg n word did you just a fictional
character from the imagination of the
collective frightened and my dead
brother's unconditional love is what i
should rely on and my kids aren't
children george
i don't even know what they're talking
about monsieurs wrote my parents love
was
conditioned hunter wrote my penis as of
late has been unconditional
mysterious wrote that is why we are
searching hunter wrote for my penis
and we will always be searching hunter
wrote it's big penis george they always
find it and i only love you because
you're black
um yeah let i mean
honestly if you're george mysterious
you're like okay i'm just gonna keep
texting and charging at 8.45 an hour is
basically the logic
of how this is going to work but here's
the amazing thing we all know that if
these were donald jr's texts
the worlds would be a flame right the
media would be all
they'd be drooling all over themselves
don jr wouldn't use this kind of
language unless he had heard it in the
home
donald jr must have learned it somewhere
he probably learned it from his racist
orange father
but joe biden because he is the great he
is the great sage white man who is going
to bring
justice racially to black people across
america
hunter is just a wayward child he's an
innocent wayward child who's experienced
so much tragedy in his life
and this candidate no i mean this has
nothing to do with joe now again
hunter is an adult at this point it
doesn't have to do with joe but
again let's be clear if this were a
republican child of a republican
president do you think they'd be
connecting it to the republican
president
what do you think the way by the way
that the daily mail got access to all of
this is because hunter biden
is an irresponsible was an irresponsible
drug addict i don't know about his
current
drug status but he left his laptop at a
repair shop
with all of this crap on it because he's
the smartest person that joe biden knows
which says a lot for joe biden's cabinet
in just one second we are going to get
to the way that race is treated
in the media because again the the way
that the left treats race is basically
if you are on the right
then you are racist simply by didn't of
your politics if you are on the left you
are not racist by dense of your politics
it's as simple as that we'll get some
more in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you
want to upgrade the look and feel of
your home one thing that you probably
haven't thought about
is the window coverings at your home now
you probably haven't thought about the
fact that your blinds look like garbage
fact that you've got like these old
crepe curtains that look like they were
from julie andrews's
mansion and sound of music they need an
update what you need is blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple
to shop top quality blinds shades and
interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and free
shipping the experts at blinds.com
understand that window treatments are
one of those household items you don't
just think about but they
can make a huge impact on the look and
feel of your home you don't need to do a
full renovation on your house it can
cost you tens of thousands of bucks
instead just change what's on the
windows and you can change the way light
comes into your home
and that makes for a totally different
feel go to blinds.com
just take a look at all the options
they've got faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades even outdoor shades
and if you're nervous about trying them
there really is no reason to be
blinds.com has helped millions of
homeowners through the process plus
they guarantee the perfect fit whether
you do it yourself or have them measure
and install everything
for you so head on over right now see
how much you can save at blinds.com when
you check out online don't forget to
tell them you heard about blinds.com
from the ben shapiro show rules and
restrictions that may apply go check
them out right now
blinds.com okay so the way that race is
treated
when it comes to the left is that again
if
you're useful to them then we cannot
declare you racist under nearly any
circumstances this is why ralph northam
is still the governor of virginia
even though he was caught wearing either
a black face or a
kkk hood right either either one or the
other right there was no third option
he's still the governor of virginia
after every democrat called for him to
step down because he was useless at the
time then later he became useful
and now you have joe biden traveling
around and campaigning with ralph
northam
and this is the way all of this works
with regard to race
okay and and if you are useless or if
you are counter to the culture
then you will be destroyed so hunter
biden will be fine he'll be fine his dad
is useful right now so hunter biden will
be fine i'll you know who's not going to
be fine
is chris harrison and chris harrison is
the host of the bachelor
or was the host of the bachelor he is
now officially out as host of the
bachelor franchise
this is only an important story insofar
as it is indicative of a mindset that is
set in in the united states
and that is if you are deemed unworthy
for not being a racist even if you were
sort of edging around a topic having to
do with race and we're unfairly deemed
racist
you will be destroyed so chris harrison
has now been forced to permanently step
down as the longtime host of the
bachelor
franchise according to the show warren
horizon and abc entertainment announced
harrison's departure in a statement
following a deadline report he was
leaving after taking an eight-figure
payout and agreeing to keep silent
on the franchise's dirty laundry this is
going to buzzfeed news
the statement said we are thankful for
his many contributions over the past 20
years wish him all the best
on his new journey his departure marks
the end of nearly two decades his host
and comes just a day after the premiere
of the new bachelorette season which is
co-hosted by two former
women leads chris harrison then tweeted
he put out an instagram in which he said
i've had a truly incredible run as host
of the bachelor franchise now i'm
excited to start a new chapter i'm so
grateful to bachelor nation for all the
memories
we have made it together now remember
the reason that he was ousted is not
because he is a racist the reason
that chris harrison just lost his job is
because he made the unfortunate slip of
suggesting that a young white woman who
had attended an antebellum-themed frat
party or
a sorority party when she was 19 ought
to be given a little grace and not treat
it as though she
was a member of the kkk or had dressed
in a white hood and was not governor of
virginia
right he said give her a little grace
this by the way was the same exact
comment
that had been made by the boyfriend of
the woman who would end up being picked
on the bachelor who was a black man like
the first black bachelor
picked this white woman he said she
should be given a little grace when
those photos emerged
chris harrison repeated it but then the
first black bachelor
decided to reverse himself after rachel
lindsay came down really hard on chris
harrison
and then he said rachel kirk connell who
is the young white woman she's really
bad
and then chris harrison was forced to
backtrack
and he apologized to the mob which you
should never ever do and he was removed
from the bachelor and then later the
first black bachelor and rachel
corconell got back together
so the only person who ended up out of a
job here
i mean sure he gets an eight figure
payout which is nice but the only person
who ended up out of an actual job
was chris harrison again for the great
crime of repeating the exact words that
the first black bachelor had said
about his white girlfriend at the time
by the way note to rachel kirk connell
after your boyfriend calls you a racist
in public you probably don't want to
date him anymore
like that's just not a relationship
that's going places but it is again
indicative of the way that racial
politics work in the united states
either
you are assimilated to the borg or you
are determined so useless that you don't
need to be assimilated to the borg
and instead you must be ousted from any
position of public power
and unfortunately this has bled down to
pretty much all
aspects of our culture it's bled down to
our colleges it has bled down
to entertainment obviously it has bled
down to our places
of work and this idea that america is
rife with white supremacy it's secret
right it's secret whites if you're like
an open kind of racist like hunter biden
is but you're still useful then you're
not part of the system of white power
structure even though hunter biden
is a powerful white man who is traded
and you want to talk about white
privilege
hunter biden being the son of joe biden
traveling around to ukraine and picking
up bags of cash
and then traveling to china and picking
up bags of cash because his last name is
i mean there is no greater example of
white privilege in america than hunter
biden
he is the essence of white privilege in
any sane society
but the idea from the left of course is
that you are truly only
in your emblematic of white privilege if
you are participatory in the system and
hunter biden's dad is trying to revise
the system so hunter biden isn't really
white privilege
hunter biden is really just this wayward
child but everybody else who lives
within the system
must be made aware of their white
supremacy and they must be they must be
taught about it
and they must be lectured about it and
they must be canceled over it
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about your safety and
security at home it can be hard to keep
an eye on your house all day whether
you're home
or not there are a thousand reasons why
protecting my home matters to me if
somebody stops by if somebody's dropping
off a package if i've got somebody who's
working on the house
i want to know what's going on in my
property is the bottom line whether i'm
at home or whether i'm not at home
at my house i can keep an eye on every
corner of our house which rings easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams to get
ring alarm for yourself
go to ring.com forward slash ben it is
the perfect way to start your ring
experience
the thing that i enjoy most besides ring
being a powerful asset for my home it's
super affordable and it was really
really easy to install
as soon as we moved from california to
florida first thing my wife said
get the ring devices on the house we did
makes us feel safe make sure that i can
keep track of my own kids
it's never been more important to see
who is at your house right now and you
can see it all in one
simple app because with ring my family
and i can keep an eye on our home no
matter where we are right from the phone
so start protecting your home today
with ring alarm go to ring.com get your
ring alarm security kit today
you can build the system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
minutes that's ring.com once more
ring.com ben so
our culture with regard to canceling
people around the issue of race has
seeped
into pretty much everything it was
amazing yesterday there was a clip of
barack obama talking about his daughters
in college and talking about how even
they understand the excesses of cancer
culture but
people are missing the point of obama
talking about this his whole point
is that canceled culture generally is
good he says sometimes it's excessive
but mostly
it's good here's barack obama talking up
he wasn't talking it down talking up
canceled culture yesterday
at least in conversations with my
daughter i think that
a lot of the dangers of cancer
culture and you know we're just going to
be condemning people all the time
at least among my daughters that they'll
acknowledge that sometimes
among their peer group or in college
campuses
you know you'll see folks going
overboard but they have a pretty good
sense of
of look um we don't
want we don't expect everybody to be
perfect we don't expect everybody to be
politically correct all the time but we
are going to call out
institutions or individuals if they
um are being cruel okay but we are going
to call out institutions or individuals
if they are being cruel and of course
that rubric expands dramatically because
all you have to do to say that an
institution is cruel is say
that they are right-wing say that they
are conservative say that they are on
the wrong side of the political aisle
again hunter biden is emblematic of the
right side of the political aisle so he
is fine he is not some
local business owner who is caught using
in a text right he is not some sort of
some local he wasn't some local dry
cleaner
who was caught saying a bad thing or an
impolitic thing on camera
and now he's going to have to be ousted
from public life right he's the son of
the president so he's totally fine
the rubric expands and contracts at will
for the democrats
again it is all about power one of the
great rules
when it comes to the left is that
everything they attribute to the right
particularly their theory that all
politics is driven by power
is actually an understanding of
themselves that they just can't see
whenever they say all politics is about
power all principle is about power when
people on the right talk about
their principles what they really mean
is that they wish to re-enshrine
their own power the left believes that
because this is what the left actually
does
people on the left are constantly
contracting and expanding terminology
they're constantly redefining things
in order to expand their own power that
is all that matters
and you can see this happening again
throughout american society
this is why for example last night
there's a cnn anchor named victor
blackwell
and he had on a texas republican state
representative named steve toth
okay and toth was talking about how
texas has now banned a critical race
theory in the classroom
okay critical race theory is not just
teaching bad things about the united
states you're allowed to teach
that there is awful stuff that's
happened in american history in texas
you're certainly allowed to teach that
what critical race theory does is it
says something different
it says that every institution in the
united states
is irrevocably and irredeemably and
inextricably
intertwined with racism that racism lies
at the root
of all institutions in the united states
and that if you are white
you benefit from the privilege the
privileges that are already embedded in
the system that white supremacy is
written into the system that every white
person in america is an unconscious
beneficiary
of that white privilege this is the case
that is made by critical race theory
it does it it is it is all about racial
essentialism your whiteness
is connected with your power and your
power is connected with systems of
whiteness that are embedded in all of
the systems that's critical race theory
in a nutshell and that's not me defining
it that's the people who actually
founded it to finance people like
richard delgado or jean
stefanczyk people like derek bell this
is how they talk about all of this stuff
so it has a very specific meaning okay
so cnn's victor blackwell however wants
to label anybody who opposes this a
racist
so he has on this state representative
named steve toth
and he asks why this is a priority in
the first place this is my favorite game
that the left plays my favorite game
okay they do something that is utterly
beyond the pale they do something that
is utterly wild
and then if you notice they're doing a
wild thing then they say why are you
even paying attention to this in the
first place
they're like okay so let's use
nickelodeon to propagandize on behalf of
trans values
well that's kind of crazy i mean those
are small children you are
propagandizing like why are you even
paying attention
why do you even care they'll have
some sort of lgbt pride segment
on blue's clues this actually happened
okay and if you notice it they're like
why are you even paying attention to
that how dare you pay attention to that
i mean after all why does that matter
it's such a small thing shouldn't kids
know about that sort of stuff
and why are you making such a big deal
is it because you're afraid of your own
sexuality
this is the way the left plays this game
it's all high school bullying nonsense
okay so this is the game that was being
played yesterday by the most trusted
name in news
cnn's victor blackwell who confronts it
again a texas republican why are you
even paying attention to the fact we're
trying to indoctrinate white kids in
school that they are
inevitably beneficiaries of a white
racist system shouldn't they be
compelled to at least
teach what is happening in the world or
give some information about what's
happening in the world around them
but that's the problem is you you guys
the left
you are the left cnn is the left you
guys have come across certainly
that is a lazy argument just answer the
question
the argument it's clear it's just answer
the question
why shouldn't teachers be compelled
to teach what is happening in the world
at the time
okay notice how he's framing this okay
notice how blackwell victor blackwell
is framing this okay the way that he's
framing this is and
you sort of have to have the context he
introduced this by saying
why shouldn't teachers have to teach
that the january 6th riots were all
about the evils of white supremacy which
is embedded in the systems
and so this texas state representative
is like because i reject your framing
your framing is in and of itself
inaccurate
your framing is all about what you wish
that january 6th was about
but that's not what january 6 was
actually about and you only want to
teach
one thing and we don't think the teacher
should be compelled to teach that one
thing
and then victor blackwell's like well
why shouldn't teachers be compelled to
teach
the truth well weird how you're defining
your opinion as the truth now victor
blackwell
weird how your critical race theory take
is now defined as the only way to teach
again notice that he's not saying why
shouldn't teachers be allowed to teach
this
he's not even making that argument which
is still not a great argument because of
course
there are there have to be some
standards as to what teachers can and
cannot teach
he's saying why shouldn't teachers be
compelled to teach it because there is
one rule as my friend eric erickson has
said when it comes to the left
and how they march through the
institutions anything
that is allowed is compelled eventually
that's the way this works right anything
that is allowed is compelled
if something is originally allowed
eventually it will be compulsory we just
want to be able to teach critical race
theory oh yeah by the way we've also
embedded it
in all of the structures of american
life such that you are now compelled to
do so or you're going to be excised from
american society
it's being taken in by our corporate
overlords
one of the things that i write about in
my new book the authoritarian moment
which comes out
in the end of july is the takeover of
all of these
institutions by radical left-wing theory
hey lockheed martin
has now admitted again and the reason
lockheed martin does this of course is
because it wishes to comply
with woke mandates from the federal
government if they demonstrate
that they've engaged in sort of woke
diversity training nonsense
then they can get along with the federal
government which pushes the exact same
thing they sent out a letter did
lockheed martin to senator tom cotton in
which they fully acknowledge
now that the company has sent 1024
employees through mandatory white male
re-education programs according to chris
ruffo who does an excellent job
on all of this stuff apparently on june
8th
june 8th or 11th of 2020 13 lockheed
martin employees attended a three-day
training course entitled white man's
caucus
administered by an outside vendor white
men as full diversity partners and since
2007 over 1 000 lockheed martin
employees
have attended this type of training
pretty incredible stuff
so all of this is being crammed down in
your entertainment it's being crammed
down on your kids
in schools it's being crammed down by
your corporations
and all of it is supposed to be about
dramatic rethinking of what america is
and what america
should be we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about your sleep
quality so as you can tell i'm
broadcasting from not my house right now
i'm broadcasting from and nowhere i'm
not broadcasting from my studio that
means i'm not sleeping in my own bed
when i don't sleep in my own bed i just
do not sleep as well why well because
when i'm in my own bed i am on
a magnificent helix sleep mattress that
was made just for me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they've got soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folk so if you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
you're matched to the mattress comes
right to your door ship for free you
don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again
helix is indeed awesome but you don't
need to take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com take that two minute
sleep quiz and get started today 10 year
warranty you can try it out for 100
nights risk free they'll pick it up for
if you don't love it but you're gonna
love it
really you have nothing to lose helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.com go check them out
right now helixsleep.com to 200 bucks
off your order alrighty so
all of this is about a complete rethink
of what america is and ought to be so
mara gay
is a writer for the new york times and
the other day
she was talking about the absolute
horror of driving around and seeing
people who fly
trump flags and in the context of
suggesting that it was terrible that she
was driving around long island and she
saw people with trump flags
she also said it was just terrible they
had trump flags and also american flags
and it was super duper terrible
because again the idea here from people
like marge
is that the american flag is a bad thing
right all of these other various flags
black lives matter flags and queer pride
matter flags and
all of these various other flags these
are all very good things
because they symbolize resistance to
authority but
the american flag is a very bad thing
the american flag is emblematic of
racism
and sexism and heteronormativity and
homophobia
and bigotry and islamophobia and all of
the other phobias that you could
possibly
imagine up to and including
arachnophobia so here's marge going
after the american flag
it's amazing the new york times has
tried to walk this back it's a little
bit too late
i was on long island this weekend uh
visiting a really
dear friend and i was really disturbed i
saw you know dozens and dozens of pickup
trucks with
uh you know uh explicatives against joe
biden
on the back of them uh trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know uh is also just
disturbing because essentially the
message was clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
i own this okay so um just a quick note
people fly american flags from
all places on the political spectrum
although increasingly not on the left
because they are upset with the american
flag moksa
gay then the new york times
communications
office put out a statement about marga's
amazing statement there right that she
was deeply afraid because she saw dozens
of american flags
nobody tell her about memorial day guys
it's super scary but
she says that she's the american flag in
conjunction with people who like trump
that's crazy oh my god it's just there
so the new york times put out a
statement saying this clip was taken out
of context well i just played you the
whole clip so
no it's not taken out of context but
then margae promptly
blows up the new york times
communications team's ability to to roll
that back here's what she just
tweeted out yesterday quote i see i'm
being trolled with the american flag
this morning
trolling a black journalist with the
american flag is not the own some people
think it is
so in other words the american flag is
really bad right she went right back to
the well
the american flag is bad because if
you're trolling black people with the
american flag you're assuming that black
people can be trolled with the american
flag which they can't be because the
american flag
is all about white supremacy okay all
how does all of this tie in
to the to the hunter biden of it all
again it is all about racism for the
left
has become a tool of policy not just
because they actually embedded in policy
but also because anything that i like is
resistance to white supremacy and
anything i don't like is white supremacy
all of the unifying features of american
life have been torn away individual
rights
are considered now they they are they
are racist
in their essence the american flag is
racist in its essence
mother's day is is sexist and it has all
the unifying features of american life
have been torn away
all that remains is raw power politics
that is
all that matters speaking of which joe
biden has now pulled the plug
on any sort of bipartisan infrastructure
talks with leading republicans
according to the new york times
president biden on tuesday ended a
weeks-long effort to reach a deal with
senate republicans
on an expansive infrastructure plan
cutting off negotiations that had failed
to persuade them to embrace his bid
to pour a trillion dollars into the
nation's aging public work system and
safety net programs
i love how the new york times just
slides in and safety net programs at the
end right there
because normally when you're talking
about infrastructure programs you'd want
to be talking about you know
infrastructure
but as we all know for democrats
everything is infrastructure
literally everything daycare is
infrastructure healthcare is
infrastructure
toilet paper is infrastructure people
who judge his bike that he rides around
after taking it out of the back of an
suv so he can pretend to be an
environmentalist that's infrastructure
too
every single thing is infrastructure so
long as democrats are pushing it
according to the new york times it was a
major setback to mr biden's efforts to
attract republican support for his top
domestic priority which should always
face long odds over the size scope and
financing of the package
most republicans have made it clear they
are willing to spend only a fraction
of what democrats want on a much
narrower initiative and boxed in any tax
increases to pay for it
on a final telephone call on tuesday
with senator shelley moore capito of
west virginia the leading republican
negotiator after days of back and forth
discussions biden made clear the divide
was too large to bridge now for those
who say that republicans will not pass
anything
with democrats that is just not true so
yesterday
there was a bill that frankly i don't
like very much i think senator mike lee
has done a good job of exploiting the
reasons why
the senate passed a bill to bolster
competitiveness with china according to
the new york times
with a bunch of republican votes it's
going to pour about 250 billion
over the next five years into scientific
research and development supposedly
although a lot of it is going to go to
sort of crony
programs for various corporations that
were kind of glove with the government
but the vote was 68-32 so all the talk
about how joe biden can't do anything
bipartisan with republicans it's just
not true it's a lie
but in order to to foment the notion
that biden is actually proposing
something moderate
they have to just ignore the fact that
the senate passed 68 to 32
a bill written by democrats and
republicans with joe biden's signature
going to go on it
shelly moore copedo said it was biden
who was unwilling to compromise she said
while i appreciate president biden's
willingness to devote so much time and
effort to these negotiations he
ultimately chose not to accept the very
robust and targeted infrastructure
package
and instead end our discussion again
republicans had offered something crazy
it was like they'd offered almost
i believe it was half a half a trillion
dollars on this thing
and apparently that wasn't enough
because they wanted to speed through a
two trillion dollar
quote unquote infrastructure package
this led mitch mcconnell to declare the
era of bipartisanship is over
now listen i think the year of
bipartisanship has been in real trouble
for
nyan 20 years basically since the left
decided that george w bush
was hitler and they were not going to
work with him anymore that was basically
2003 after the no child left behind act
from then on
it's hard to think of a major piece of
legislation that has received
significant bipartisan support so it's
been nearly 20 years since we've had any
really significant piece of legislation
with serious bipartisan
support that isn't sort of an emergency
relief bill or something
okay but here's mitch mcconnell saying
now the democrats aren't even trying
right i mean forget about clintonian
third way there will be no deals made
here
as you look to uh what the majority
leader has in mind for june
it's pretty clear the era of
bipartisanship is over
we passed six bills so far this year
significant bills on a bipartisan basis
um bills that came out of committee that
had
buy-in from both sides but i think
that's coming to a screeching halt
okay and he's right about that of course
the the fact is that
democrats have basically decided that
the way that they are going to win
electoral electoral power is they're
going to just castigate their political
opponents
as racist and then hope for the best
that's the new deal because they're not
getting what they want joe manchin is
not going to bust the filibuster
christian cinema is not going to do it
they're not going to ram through these
giant
huge packages unless they're done
through reconciliation and their
republicans have very little say anyway
so democrats really are left with just
the option of calling their opponents
racist
because as the policies fail this is all
they're going to have
okay in just one second we're going to
get to the democrats kamala harris
problem because they have a very very
serious kamala harris problem on their
hands we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about something fantastic
you can do for your parents okay so out
in their garage right now you have a
bunch of old film reels and vhs tapes
you don't have a projector
you don't have any sort of vcr because
you haven't had one for 15 years
so all that stuff's just falling apart
out there all your old memories are
literally falling apart why not take
that stuff digitize it preserve it
forever
this is what legacy box does i've done
this for my parents it is fantastic
watching them be able to open up
via digital media some old video of me
as a kid or my sisters his kids
or even old film reels their parents i
mean it really is an incredible
experience and it's preserved for future
generations
legacy box makes this happen for you
it's a way for you to easily and
affordably digitally preserve your past
the process from start to finish
is super simple you pack you send their
team digitizes everything by hand
and then you enjoy and you get back
perfectly preserved digital copies on
thumb drive dvd or the cloud
ready to watch share and enjoy they're
going to keep you up to date with
regular email updates throughout the
process
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home videos
and movies and photos they've helped
over 850 000 families preserve their
past my family is one of those families
get started preserving your family's
legacy today go to legacybox.com
shapiro get an incredible 50 off your
very first order
buy today take advantage of the
exclusive offer and then you can send in
the materials whenever you are ready go
to legacybox.com
shapiro save 50 while supplies last
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
the democrats very very serious kamala
harris problem first
when it comes to political commentary
there's no doubt the daily wire has the
best political commentary on the market
today but there's any of my
unbelievable podcast episodes let's face
it they're spectacular
or any of our other daily podcasts or
our new investigative journalism team
or big tech and sports coverage from our
writers there's always something worth a
read or a listen
but we move fast in a fast-paced world
if you don't keep up you might fall
behind which is why you need to download
the daily wire app so you don't miss
anything
even if you're not a daily wire
subscriber you'll be the first to know
what's trending with mobile
notifications for the latest news
all your favorite content only a touch
away so download the daily wire app stay
up to speed with the freshest
conservative voices around
no matter where you are get that app
right now you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
now meanwhile the democratic party is
finding itself with a bit of a kamala
harris problem
now this problem was pretty obvious when
she completely ditched out in the middle
of the primaries
after having held the lead you'll
remember after the first primary debate
in which she called
joe biden now the man that she declares
to be the greatest living human
a racist you'll recall that if it had
not been apparently for people like joe
biden
thank god joe biden was not able to stop
a little girl like her from getting
ahead
is what she actually said in that first
debate now of course and then she
suggested that he should step out when
there are allegations of sexual
misconduct by joe biden and now of
course
everything is hunky-dory well kamala
harris was such a bad candidate that she
fell apart i mean she really just
blew up on launch when she was when she
was a candidate
for the presidency back during the
primaries now joe biden because she's
black and a woman
and again he said this okay this is not
anybody implying some sort of motive
here he said openly he was going to pick
a black woman
and then he picked a black woman so
those were qualifications that he
himself selected and he selected it
because he wanted the identity politics
crowd to know that he was serious about
all of his priorities there's only one
problem
joe biden is adult in nearly 80. and
there's very little expectation that
he's going to run for re-election
and the democratic party is not going to
have the ability to oust comel harris in
favor of anybody else because she's just
going to attack anyone else
as trying to oppose her on the basis of
her race and her sex
so the democratic party has a serious
common harass problem and the biggest
problem is she's terrible at this
she is just horrifying at politics
it demonstrates truly how there's this
great idea out there that in order to
reach the top of american politics you
have to be good at things
let the last several decades disabuse
you of that notion
no you don't you can be a complete
dunder-headed and make it to the
top of american politics you can be
utterly incompetent on camera
and be at the head of american politics
in fact you can be
not only nearly senile but barely able
to speak
english and you can become president of
the united states
it's a great country i mean look at this
country this is
when they say that anybody can become
president in the united states they mean
literally anybody
can can become presidents in the united
states but i'll tell you one person
who's not going to be elected president
in the united states that is kamala
harris because this lady is just
terrible at it so
she was down in guatemala yesterday
she's not visited the us border yet
to explain why exactly the biden border
administration policy is so bad
but she did go down to guatemala where
she has pledged to go back to the obama
plan which is what if we just
threw a bunch of money at the problem
you'll notice that there's a common
theme to all democratic plans and that
is what if we just throw a bunch of
money at the problem
so they're like what if we just throw a
bunch of money at the problem and the
president of guatemala he's like um
well you know that's not going to help
because your border policy sucks here is
the president of guatemala
basically lecturing the biden
administration yesterday
the talk that they were going to allow
family reunification made the coyotes
take a lot of children towards the
border of the united states
yeah so basically their crappy policy
caused
more people to to try and cross the
border illegally
then just a couple of days ago kamala
harris was asked
about not visiting the border by lester
holt and things got
super awkward because kamala harris
again there's nothing funnier in life
to kamala harris than a question she
can't answer it's the funniest thing
that has ever happened to her
i mean it's it's like watching it's like
watching an old jim carrey flick
for kamala harris she just she can't
help herself when a question is asked of
her that makes her slightly awkward
she just starts laughing and and falling
and cackling like
like an insane person it's wild so here
is kamala harris
losing it when lester hold to ask her
you know why haven't you been down to
the border again
do you have any plans to visit the
border at some point
you know we are going to the border
we've been to the border
so this whole this whole this whole
thing about the border we've been to the
border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border
um you totally understand the point that
he's making which is why you were lying
one second about go about
having visited the border i do love that
exchange it's pretty spectacular we have
visited the border
you haven't visited the border i haven't
i think that lester holt is actually
utilizing the old jedi mind trick on her
it's pretty spectacular those who are
weak of mine i mean like
really really wild stuff so she got
shellacked over this of course because
she should be shellacked over this the
reason that she hasn't visited the
border is because she doesn't want an
awkward photo op of having to walk
among cells that are filled with small
children because of her administration's
terrible border policy okay but the the
real takeaway here is that kamala harris
is
horrifyingly bad at this she's just an
untalented politician
she is she's a like i understand she got
elected senator
in california okay for a democrat to be
elected senator in california actually
it turns out is not all that tough
because california is a one-party state
again she's really not very good at this
and then she doubled down on being not
very good at this
so she was asked again about visiting
the border and once again
you have to think that there is some
sort of almost neurological trigger when
she's asked a question like this she was
asked about visiting the border it's
awkward
and she starts to laugh again again
listen i i've been to the border before
i will go again
but when i'm in guatemala
dealing with root causes i think we
should have a conversation about what's
going on in guatemala
hilarious hi hilarious again she just
can't stop herself she cannot
okay well this has led to some
awkwardness for the administration
jen sackey it it is pretty amazing that
the administration hasn't just been like
okay fine senator the border
jen sackey over at the white house was
asked about this and she's like maybe
she'll go to the border at some point
yes i also have aspirations to travel to
ireland i mean like we all have
aspirations to i want to go on an
alaskan cruise but i love the fact that
they're treating
what should be sort of a baseline
mandatory political move
is like you know maybe at some point
she'll go to the border i mean there's
lots of places to go
i mean she could go to albuquerque for
some reason or you know maybe she needs
to be up in nebraska
there's a lot going on for kamal harris
her portfolio of course
includes things like the border and also
voting rights neither of which she has
done anything about
she's just so good at this guy she's
such a talented politician we need the
media to form a fan club for her
actually so here's jen sackey jenn
sackey trying to uh trying to
make excuses for kamal harris here at
some point she may go to the border
we'll see
but she's in the northern triangle now
to have discussions with leaders with
uh community leaders with civil society
leaders
uh with the embassy about how we can
work together and
obviously she's made a couple of
announcements already probably more to
come before she comes back to the united
states uh oh
jen sackey has got to be so irritated
with having to defend kamala harris who
truly
is not very good at this by the way
again it is
it is an amazing thing that don't worry
people will still try to make
fetch a thing right they're going to try
to make kamala harris they've been
trying
right they have like these online fan
clubs that have no members and then they
have
members of the media who ask her
questions like kamal harris i voted for
you this actually happened at the press
conference yesterday
a lady who represented herself as a
representative of univision suggested
that she was really excited to have
become a citizen and voted for kamala
harris which is definitely the way that
you lead off
an objective journalistic question here
we go
our next question will come from maria
fernanda
at univision thank you madam vice
president for me it's an honor because i
actually got to vote for the first time
as a nationalized citizen and i voted
for you oh my god
and then oh thank you okay first of all
you know what points for transparency
i wish that everybody in the white house
press corps had to do that wouldn't that
be great is if they had to lead off
every question with who they voted for
i actually kind of think we should make
that mandatory maybe it should be that
jim acosta has to announce who he voted
for before he asks any questions
maybe it would be more accurate than
what they're typically doing so what is
harris doing to try and fight back on
all of this
she's going to fall back on the lady
card now one of the things that i love
most
about democrats falling back on
essential characteristics like sex is
that they don't even believe the
characteristics exist
so apparently kamala harris is inviting
all of the female senators
to her house to have a chat now i have a
question
how do we know they're female i mean
serious question if you're if you're on
the left because we have been informed
that women
biological women are mere birthing
persons because some men
have vaginas too so even a biological
check won't
answer the question truly but kamala
harris is going to have
i am woman hear me roar knight over at
the vp's
establishment in annapolis apparently
she has invited all of the female
senators to her residence for dinner
next week
bringing back what were regular
bipartisan dinner parties that's
windowed after tough election cycles in
2016 and 2020.
all 24 female senators 16 democrats
eight republicans were invited to the
dinner at june 15th at the observatory
according to three senate sources a
get-together coming at the height of
negotiations over infrastructure
a harris aide confirmed the dinner is a
go why of course are they doing
like women only they're doing women only
because they have to
the fact that kamala harris is super
important because she is a woman and
also because she is a black woman
and also very much a woman who is black
those are the reasons why kamala harris
is an important person and was selected
for her job
she was not selected because she's a
good politician gang she wasn't
amy klobuchar did better than she did in
the primaries nobody talked about amy
klobuchar there's only one reason why
okay in any case says politico the
quarterly dinners were started by former
senators barbara mikulski of maryland
and kay bailey hutchinson of texas
they were hosted at the home of a
different senator every six weeks with
each lawmaker bringing a different dish
but since mikulski retired
in 2017 the dinners became less regular
two republican sources said the bond
between the women started to fracture
with the aggressive campaigning
against former senator kelly ayotte
republican of new hampshire in 2016 and
then worsened when they went after susan
collins
another complicating factor was that
four democratic senators were running
against each other for president in 2020
harris gillibrand klobuchar and
elizabeth warren the sister
the sisterhood has certainly faded okay
well this is all
very exciting stuff for kamala harris
i'm glad that we can have these sorts of
these sorts of dinners maybe that will
save
her her fading vice presidency okay
meanwhile
some bad news for senate democrats so
some democrats have been suggesting all
along that we need a bipartisan
commission to investigate what happened
on january 6. well it turns out there is
a bipartisan
senate commission that looked at what
happened on january 6.
it's coming out of a a joint report
that was issued by a senate committee
okay and you know what it showed it
showed security failures the word trump
does not really appear in the document
because it really was not about trump it
turns out
that lots of people have lots of crazy
ideas and what stops them
is the thin blue line what stops them
are the cops in the right places at the
right times and the real problem on
january 6th
was not trump's rhetoric per se that
could be problematic in its own right
but the real problem is that there
weren't enough members of security to
stop people from breaching the capital
this was clearly the problem
if you had to nail down what was the
biggest problem on january 6 that was
the biggest problem on january 6th
none of that is to suggest that trump's
rhetoric between the election and
january 6th was good
or productive i said many times i think
that it really was not
i disagreed with virtually all of it but
the real problem
was security okay and that is what you
should focus on if you're talking about
protecting the capital building
in the future democrats are very upset
about this however
so according to the new york times top
federal intelligence agencies failed to
adequately warn law enforcement
officials
before the january 6th riot that
pro-trump extremists were threatening
violence including plans to storm the
capital
infiltrate its tunnel system and bring
guns according to a new report by two
senate committees that outlines
large-scale failures that contributed to
the deadly assault
an fbi member on january 5th warning of
people traveling to washington for war
at the capitol
never made its way to top law
enforcement officials
so it never even got to the top levels
the capitol police failed to widely
circulate information its own
intelligence unit has collected
as early as mid-december about the
threat of violence on january 6th
the first congressional report on the
capital right is the most comprehensive
and detailed account to date of the
dozens of intelligence failures
miscommunications and security lapses
that led to what the bipartisan team of
senators that assembled it concluded was
an unprecedented
attack on american democracy
the 127-page joint report a product of
more than three months of hearings and
interviews and reviews of thousands of
pages presents a damning portrait of the
preparations and response
at multiple levels law enforcement
officials did not take seriously threats
of violence and a dysfunctional police
force at the capitol lacked the capacity
to respond effectively
when those threats materialized so
nobody had a plan
okay so again the real problem on
january 6th
in terms of what actually happened was
failures of intelligence failures of law
enforcement and people should be fired
but now democrats are mad because what
they really want january 6 to be about
is not those failures but about
president trump so that's why chuck
schumer is fighting that about a report
his own senate democrats presided over
here is structural whining about it
just as glaring is what the report
didn't consider
indeed what was not allowed it was not
allowed to consider
the report did not investigate report on
or hardly make
any reference to the actual cause the
actual
impetus for the attack on january the
sixth
with the exception of a brief reference
to former president trump's remarks at
the ellipse
senate republicans insisted that the
report exclude anything having to do
with the cause of the insurrection
okay but the reality is that the cause
of the quote-unquote insurrection the
cause of that
is very much up for debate because trump
did say
peacefully protest at the capitol
building
this really does expose what the
democrats want from january 6 they don't
want to talk about
what actually allowed january 6 to
happen namely the security failures
what they want to talk about is the
ideology and the politics that's what
this whole thing
has been about alrighty coming up a
little bit later today we'll be back
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show in the meantime go check
out the michael knowles show that is
available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
bourne
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowski
editing is by adam scievitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
if you want to cut through the madness
of our politics and culture and know
what's really going on and what it
really means head on over to the michael
knowles show
where we can all bask in the simple joys
of being right
see you there